a think tank that advises Facebook is
offering its help to Saudi Arabia in the
handling the fallout caused by the
murder of journalist Jim Alka Sergey an
article from the Atlantic Council
advises Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
to refocus Western thinking by
redoubling his efforts to reform Saudi
society the Atlantic Council describes
the murder of kesaji as brutal foolish
and irresponsible but it goes on to
argue that severing US ties with the
Saudis would strengthen China and Russia
investigative journalist max Blumenthal
believed that's a common theme for US
think tanks this is completely in
keeping with the Atlantic Council's
behavior what's shocking is that
Facebook is now paying them upwards of
five hundred thousand dollars to vet
political content and maintain the
integrity of their website while they're
defending essentially defending the
killing of a journalist there's no
question that there is an intersection
between kind of pay-for-play policy
papers and op-eds and punditry and the
thinking of those who the Atlantic
Council chooses to hire and that you
know can have a powerful effect in
Washington particularly in our media
which doesn't tend to solicit opinions
from working journalists investigative
journalists or academics and often
relies on think-tank fellows so you
basically when you turn on cable news in
the US you get more senior fellows than
a retired persons Association because
they simply rely on these pay-for-play
think tanks to tell people what to think
okay Shoji who wrote for the Washington
Post was killed at the beginning of
October here's a quick reminder of what
happened
[Music]
you